le 21 janvier 2019 les supporters
nantais tout le monde du football
apprenait la tragique disparition du
joueur emiliano sala yano salah a
disparu à bord d'un jet privé au dessus
de la manche près des îles anglo
normandes alors qu'il soutenait la 36e
journée de ligue 1 opposant nice à
saint-etienne et chants entonnés par le
kop niçois contre emiliano sala ont été
entendus
[Musique]
m
pour vocation honteuse de la part des
supporters suite à la défaite de leur
équipe samedi dernier face à nantes en
finale de la coupe de france et
entraîneur de l'ogcnice christophe
galtier a tenu à condamner fermement ces
chants injurieux la commission de
discipline de la lfp a quant à elle été
saisi alors scandale avec des supporters
niçois qui se moque de la mort tragique
d'un joueur de foot nos stades sont ils
devenus incontrôlables
bonsoir gilles alors gilles vous êtes
consultant consultant a aimé vous
consommez g c'est incroyable ça
c'est
comment dire
galtier a dit qu' il avait perdu moi
j'en ai un entraîneur dé dégueulasse
j'ai pas d'autre mot ouais je vois pas
parce que c'est ma prémédité en plus il
faut le sa part et le change pour pour
arriver là et pour faire ce champ pour
le prémédité
donc je sais pas ce qu'ils ont dans la
tête moi ces gens là faut pas oublier
que c'était les mêmes qui au mois d'août
avait déjà eu le fameux match nice
marseille vous avez balancé des
bouteilles étaient descendus sur le
terrain pour faire le coup de poing avec
les marseillais c'est toujours les mêmes
et honnêtement je me pose la question de
ce que fait le président niçois
pour la sécurité de son stade puisqu'il
ya des pc de sécurité dans les stades on
peut pratiquement compter le nombre de
poils qu'ils ont dans l'aîné d'emmener
les supporters i7 ian 30-40 type
il ya le champ qui part il reste dans lé
reste lui dans les tribunes il descend
même pas avec deux types pour aller les
voir pour leur dire et où vous arrêtez
tout de suite il reste tranquillement il
reste tranquillement au ou alors ils
étaient peut-être rester au bar du
soleil de la croisette pour manger sont
en bagnole je sais pas s'il est au stade
n'ont pas bougé mais
je sais pas j'ai pas de mots parce que
c'est le sait nous c'est une majorité
silencieuse qui emmerdent une c'est une
minorité silencieuse qui attendent un
changement d'une majorité si on savait
patients se stabiliser avec une
j'ai tout à fait mais bien compris ouais
faut aussi préciser monsieur favard que
si vous vous élevez et son look a raison
contre ça c'est parce que vous avez
longuement travaillé que le président de
nantes que vous avez des antécédents
quand même
ensuite ensuite non mais laissez moi
finir non mais jusqu'ici celles qu'elle
préside
val-de-marne et des marques qui t'a
voilà un camion oui mais y'a pas un
souci mais il faudrait 6 et qui sont les
gens alors après vous appeler au
président de nice parce que vous l'aimez
pas vous mettez tous les supporters de
mise dans le même panier j'ai pas mais
moi je suis pas certain ligne j'ai dit
voilà c'est une idée mais je connais
l'homme et les bottes je connais votre
discours mais moi j'avais menti à
levante vouloir les céphalées va parler
légèrement invite donc le problème
problème il vivait depuis très longtemps
que vous êtes dans le milieu du foot
mais vous vous l'avez jamais dénoncée
moi dans une ford gt gt du temps de
baisser ces taux avaient dénoncé wim
avait même dénoncé mois concerné
il a un problème avec moi mais chamakh
est
alors il m'a empêché de travailler il
m'a mis sur des listes noires il agit d
un il a été violent avec des amis à moi
des collègues les a longuement bousculer
voir le jour hier mais quand il fait de
travailler quand me savard il faut quand
il faut être honnête ici voilà dire qui
on est contre il ya c'est vous c'est
vous qui parlez de netteté oui
absolument avant d'être là bas ça oui il
parle et ben oui oui si j'avais parlé de
malhonnête ps voudrait regarder mais on
est de nature
moi je souffre tout ce que j'ai fait
dans ma vie pouvait pas de ça il ya des
choses à dire
je
suis venu sur le plateau pour vous
entendre bah oui bon pour vous en tant
que vous donc c'est ça ou vous l'avez
franche est venu pour me
dire j'ai dû les deux trois fois bien
sûr les a pas rencontrés la croisée
croisé croisés oui pourquoi dit on vous
l'avait bousculé et insulté notre abbé
je sais mais c'est lui qui distribue
mais cette combine
vous avez des collègues ou ses nuits du
bois seule recrue dans un trou tout le
monde
[Rires]
gilles verdez je sens quand cette merde
c qui vous connaît
la chance vous avez la chance d'être ici
monsieur
qui s'en étaient pris à des gens mais
non c'est pas danser les très bons
ballons séoul et les autres sociaux ou
après tout le monde balance rien les
gens vous n'avez pas vous n'avez pas
bousculer des collègues à l'équipe noire
est écarté de l'antenne 3 x 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
j'ai
hérité par j'attendais cette noté gilles
parce qu'ils n'ont plus alors je vais
rétablir la vérité vous la connaissez
pas la première fois que j'ai été mis à
l'index de l'antenne est un chien ça va
je vous ai dit je vais pas le répéter
vous parlez plus fort qu'un lapin mais
vous pourrez beaucoup moins vite l'asie
font côté maintenant vous avez compris
assez laborieux qui m'a pris à la chaîne
tv courir et c'est pas vous on est
l'actuelle maison voilà la première fois
que j'ai été mis à l'index c'est parce
que j'avais appelé ça caille j'avais dit
au lieu sakai venait d'arriver à
marseille et j'avais dix ans qu'un
vendeur de sushis à droite voilà voilà
voilà non mais c'est vrai la loi là
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'ici vous
vous dites pas ce genre à regarder êtes
vous non mais j'ai dit non mais voilà on
va pas ressasser le premier point le
deuxième fois la deuxième fois ses fans
non mais si c'est pas con mais c'est pas
grave c'est que c'est pas un problème la
deuxième fois c'est parce que j'ai dit à
un chroniqueur exactement comme ci comme
ça se passe ici quelques phrases cette
armée ne peut pas le gérer j'ai dit j'ai
dit tout simplement que s'ils continuent
à rappeler il allait prendre une tape
dans la durée j'ai dit ni manger ni je
les paie et je vais non mais je vais
venir te défendre à présent leurs
chroniqueurs à qu'il a dit ça c'est un
mec qui fait beaucoup de mal hein et un
moment il a eu raison gilles de lui dire
tu vas prendre les tartes dans la gueule
soit refusé il s'agit du mal à vous avez
du monsieur c'est la scission tes amis
ce ne sont pas les gens là n'ont jamais
chasser sur est la troisième fois c'est
parce que pendant le championnat
d'europe
les belges et un gars c'est un petit peu
de gnac nous casser un petit peu les
burnes j'ai dit tout simplement que les
belges allaient être battu derrière
rentrer chez eux manger des frites voilà
donc l'ignorance complète et moneygram
com vous êtes de toute votre vie voilà
c'est vote vous avez vous mené une vie
d'ignorance mais c'est très bien de
chaque projet
le mec à qui il a dit tu vas prendre une
part de laguiole c'est un mec qui fait
beaucoup beaucoup de mal hein je viens
ce qu'un vent et pas vraiment pour agir
dans ça y est les mouches changent
voilà donc c'est sûr la peine de
défendre des petits copains ici j'ai
défendu en personne jeudi elle a défendu
des petits copains
on n'a jamais semblé personnes jefferson
a pas de pognon chine pendu dans le
voilà merci à l'épreuve je vois que vous
vous êtes un supporters de de ces gens
qui ont changé sans genre de chant tous
je lis ici aussi c'est heureusement 10
avril à des chronos 48 47 mineurs et
deux majeurs du j5 votre métier à votre
façon c'est à dire je trouve que coups
droits dans tous à tout droit avec un
grand virage dans le milieu mais
monsieur verdez vous êtes démasqué
depuis très longtemps dans leurs yeux
donc vous inquiétez pas c'est pas moi
qui va avoir peur de vous braquer
attaqué le président de nice mais oui
j'ai hâte accueillir et sa cuisine made
in y voilà c'est pas digne de ces
caisses qui est pas digne il est
président il est président il est
président délégué il a un salaire à six
chiffres il n'est pas capable de
descendre de ceux de deux chiffres de sa
tribune oui à six chiffres il est pas
caché à banias un chiffre par mois bah
oui non à la à l'année
ce
que vous
vous inquiétez pas j'ai une attention
j'ai pris
de le dire mais c'est horrible je
regardais ce qui va me défendre alors le
problème il est qu'il n'est pas capable
de descendre et d'aller voir sa tribune
et de leur dire de se taire pour être au
moins d'accord là-dessus non pas
partiellement pas mais comme vous n'avez
pas de courage vous non plus vous serez
pas descendu ans donc c'est pas le
problème vous êtes la bonne vous êtes de
la même manière c'est à dire que quand
on met le pantalon le matin il faut pas
oublier certaines choses là dans la
chambre à coucher il faut que tous
mettent dedans
et
je vous savez quand vous parle je pense
que gilles peut être ton style
voilà le truc donc à partir de ce moment
là déjà la première fois il avait dit
que c'était la faute de payet qui
prenaient des trucs dans la gueule
c'était sa faute c'est il s'était rendu
ridicule là il a rien dit ils ont ils
ont envoyé un communiqué l'ong il n'a
rien dit pas un mot rien les supporters
se sont excusés par jour
sans attendre est ce que je valais péter
schep qu'un fan et je m'excuse m
fusent à l'hébergement c'est quand eux
ils s'excusent vous êtes d'accord quand
d'autres personnes c'est ce que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord vous est à géométrie
variable rosa bon marché il fait pas bon
marché de m'en voudras pendant le vol
gilles par les soupes et les objets non
mais c'est vous alliez un tant soit peu
de temps en temps dans les stades vous
verriez corps au niveau des 60 ans et où
il ya longtemps que les supporters pour
encourager leur équipe et c'est pas le
faux pas d'un petit groupe qui doit
faire qu'on s'acharne sur l'ensemble des
gens qui vont au stade c'est le peuple
qui va au stade ils ont commis un faux
pas ils se sont excusés mais les absout
vous êtes de parti-pris vous acharnez
sur nice je suis sans doute qu'il
entendait embaucher comme vous rendez
pas vous faire un succès mais voilà
un mail à ses jeux ont
jamais perdu je sais que j'ai jamais
rempli un cv jamais une lettre de
motivation on est toujours jamais bossé
c'est m
[Applaudissements]
alors vive la syrie agent de joueurs de
meadows il
toujours au lignage et wafa va
alors viennent pas taper les pompes sur
des grosses d'accord soit 10 en trois
ans il en
30 secondes je m'énervais tu vas tu
t'énerves et toi t'as pas vu détaillé
dans un casse-cou de bal musette
[Applaudissements]
honte à lui entame une seule fois
ok
[Applaudissements]
à des rôles dans la vie
jet
tours n'a plus rien dans la
[Applaudissements]
la formation des mouches sur les fleurs
du kenya
[Applaudissements]
je me suis amusé à venir ici parce que
j'ai vu que t'es fait une belle pomme de
terre
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que moi j'ai rien à dire moi
ça fait cinquante ans que je suis dans
le milieu du foot ça fait sentir bien
dire du montreux doublé
[Applaudissements]
avec toi j'ai dit moi je charge et j'ai
fait moi même
rigolo
lui dans la vase estime c'est monsieur
favard pas
s'il te plaît si toi tu es déjà pas mort
et spa polymorphe
si on fait des bonds
[Applaudissements]
quid des gros du nord
[Rires]
non mais je lui dis alors j'aime
beaucoup l'île voilà comment ça vous
amuse bien croyable voulait qu'à
regarder j'adore j'adore ce qu'il fait
mais il est là une fois tous les six
mois les bénévoles rendrait plus à
chaque match on n'en vaut plus il est
alors moi je l'adoré
moi aussi j'aime bien bravo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
aujourd'hui nous emmerder qui t'a valu
une exclusion juppé très la gueule moi
[Musique]
comme ça mais moi j'étais dans les loges
marie avec de l'eau il y avait des gars
laquelle il avait il à tout prix un
problème avec gilles oui j'ai un
problème avec lui parce que il est
malhonnête c'est que ça se voit mais
il est hors enseigne dans le milieu du
foot mais avec qui la france n'est cassé
un bâton il va il va emberlificoté les
présidents et se prête en agent de
joueur il se prétend journaliste il
serait temps que mais je me suis jamais
prétendue journal alors il m'a dit
qu'ils n'étaient pas que l'on ai dit
d'ailleurs je te jure un ba oui mais ils
vous êtes quoi alors finalement
s'arrêtait maintenant affaire dont je
suis retraité voilà les retraités ouais
ok je respecte les retraités voilà je
suis
[Rires]
donc
y'a quoi tu veux un rencard ou quoi tu
cherche quelque chose je n'attends pas
moi que jusqu'au début après que vous
insultez les gens sur twitter des fois
without et ben voilà c'est vrai et ben
voilà les fans ont même pas voilà
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai tu t'en parle
aux gens sur twitter non je mens propre
au genre en france gens qui passent leur
temps à insulter
des gens préfèrent des gens là mais pas
des soeurs quand les quand on me pose
une question par exemple quand on me dit
je sais pas quand on me dit mais tient
le numéro de téléphone laurent blanc
machin je demande à ta soeur etc
tu parles pas ça comme moi par exemple
on vient pas en arabie non mais on est
habitué je suis habitué de rien de chez
les lions sur twitter je suis pas du
tout aux jeux sur les réseaux celle du
tout près des 1 dans mes dirigeants ça
me dérange pas mais être comment ça
donne en tous les cas la présence se
déhanche ça c'est sûr mais ça m'amuse et
moi
pour la la famille
gilles verdez pas ce que vous dites
voilà ils se sont excusés mais imaginez
mais pour la famille de joueurs quand
ils ont entendu ces chants
sais c'est pas possible c'est sur ma
position est minoritaire mais c'est une
erreur majeure c'est grave mais je vais
être un peu provocateur il ya eu pire
dans les tribunes de foot et
de la violence il ya eu des choses il ya
eu d aider les exactions et tout ça donc
voilà je suis très dont je suis très
triste mais ils se sont excusés raciste
oui oui bien sûr du racisme voilà il ya
eu il ya isabelle apparaître de la
famille oui mais je sais c est cerné le
thé des joueurs si je suis pour la
station on les connaît et si
effectivement à chaque fois il ya des
débordements qui sont outranciers et
inadmissible il ya maintenant quand on
rentre dans les stades etc il ya des
vidéos on les connaît ils sont ils de
vous donner dans les tribunes là les
visages on les connaît on les reconnaît
donc imagine leur carte puisque c'est
des fans absolus là ces gens là ils
doivent être exclues du stade ils seront
sanctionnés d'ailleurs mais quand on
s'en prend au club en tant que tel comme
monsieur favard c'est là où je ne suis
pas d'accord
n'est pas responsable de 30 à 40 des
corps du père si mais si on peut parler
sans sembler un club de foot c'est un
organisateur de spectacles quand vous
allez au théâtre il ya un organisateur
de spectacles 6 passe quelque chose dans
la salle il est responsable et au foot
c'est exactement la même chose donc vous
êtes automatiquement responsable
je m'en prends pas au club je m'en
prends parce que il ya déjà eu des
antécédents c'est pour ça que je manque
que ce que je tape mais le problème il
ya déjà eu des antécédents au mois
d'août il n'a pas bronché par le club
car bien des jeux spectacles vous
connaissez même pas les dossiers c'est
la ligue 2 le spectacle qui d'ailleurs
sans doute sanctionnera ben oui mais
c'est ça peut avoir des gens qui sont
compétents mais tu peux alors retirés
à partir c'est sur les jambes conneries
comme ça si c'est pas les clubs sont
responsables de ce qui se passe dans
leur stade c'est la ligue est
responsable de l'organisation du
spectacle c'est là sur la ligue qu'il
faut taper mais comme vous avez des amis
à la ligue féminine
à vue sur le président de l'ars est de
raconter des conneries maintenant ça
suffit a pas la ligue ils sont
responsables de brial à la ligue ils
sont quoi à la ligue président de la
ligue qui est nommé par qui par les
présidents elle va tarder sur les
présidents la ligue pour le progrès la
ligue il dit n'importe quoi chaque
branche et non mais franchement sur le
rocher ces règlements mais tout
le stade
la dirigeante et ce qu'il veut alors si
tu veux complètement le haut du sud et
la rive mois
valérie n'importe
présidente
avant un hommage idées sans pitié sur
charlie c'est quand même le club qui est
responsable mais au delà de salles
réglementairement c'est la ligue qui va
sévir mais c'est la wii mais c'est la
vie qui organisent les spectacles
sportifs via qua non non il sait les
clubs qui sont responsables chez eux à
bien cela la ligue organise leur sac à
des sentiments quand il ya des problèmes
c'est l'ailé et les clubs sont
responsables de ce qui se passe chez eux
et vous est ce stade est carrément et de
la sécurité du stade le club la sécurité
du stade naturel de ski à tata fallait
attaquer raymond n'est pas du tout
normal c'est connais beaucoup gérald
nommé il excuse moi mais tu es partie
pied au plancher tu veux te faire savoir
le problème c'est qu'il faut pas se
faire avoir il faut faire c'est ultra là
qu'ils ont juste complètement déconner
et qui ont l'an et qui ont lancé une
sorte de chanson complètement obscènes
et dégueulasse est à gerber donc moi je
suis d'accord avec toi il faut pas
stigmatiser tous les ultras parce qu'il
ya plein d'ultra qui font des choses
formidables les soutes de bienfaisance
pour leur club et celles qui sont
extraordinaires et ses lames sellam des
clubs bien évidemment mais cela là il
faut les dégager si galtier d'ailleurs a
été très clair on était très nette à
l'idée très digne et pardon moi c'est
pas des abrutis pour moi ils sont le
reflet d'une époque parce que tu n'es
qui se sont excusés ils sont et ce sont
ces monuments excuses et oui ils ont
quand même parler de l'humour des ultras
autoire de six mois deux lotos des
dictionnaires heures
il dit que c'est pas une erreur nous
aviez mois sûr que sur les stades on
voit des saluts nazis des cris de singe
des chansons comme ça là une erreur sont
excusés donc il ya un classement dans
l'horreur de ce que tu casses toi nazis
au dessus de cris de singe au dessus de
cette chanson et gratifie ses excuses et
sabha et d'autres pas et d'ailleurs ils
les saluts nazis s'il s'excuse ça passe
aussi par ce concept il espère que les
piles indignez-vous pour des prêts truc
mais ça c'est par d'après oui à 30% des
chambres sont d'accord à jean a way is
il s'est même dé donner votre avis
copains tu travailles sa vie ce sont les
bienvenus